The first episode was the King of Spain
Alonso against science as if it were
a World Cup and de
facto it was a midfield game and
12th place D. I watched the next
episode because I
wanted to give it another chance after 45 minutes
So that didn't work at all, it was embarrassing and
I came back and
forgot about it and said then we're
not going to take part anymore and then R a
friend called me and said she would like to see if
it would be possible to have tickets for the
Austrian Grand Prix and said
for whom  yes for my two sons, they
were 18 or 19 years old, pretty cool,
I thought boys were interested in
Formula 1, yes we love drive to
survive, I thought maybe
my assessment was wrong and it
was clear there
[music].